[Music]
[Applause]
so um one of the stories i'm going to be
doing tomorrow on the show is that nancy
pelosi has announced the house will be
taking up a vote on an assault weapons
ban and even if it passes the house
i don't think that there's 10
republicans right now who are interested
in passing an assault weapons ban in the
senate so it'll probably die
but one of the incredible things is that
canada
is doing more about guns as a result of
the shooting and shootings in the united
states than the united states is doing
about guns which is just unbelievable uh
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
announced earlier this week
that they are going to be freezing
handgun sales which will stop canadians
from being able to buy sell import or
transfer guns
this wouldn't stop anybody who currently
has a gun from being able to use it at a
shooting range nobody has to give up
their guns they're not confiscating any
any guns
but in 2020 trudeau passed a ban on 1500
makes and models of assault style guns
and now they are going to be going
further you know whatever you think
about justin trudeau and whatever you
think about the effectiveness of these
types of bands
it's stunning that as a reaction to
what's happening here which is not
happening there they are saying
we have to make things even tighter it's
truly remarkable
right here in the u.s it's politically
infeasible to do basically any gun
control measure at this point whereas in
canada they do have the power to do it
and so in a sense it's almost like
justin trudeau is mocking us like
mocking our system of government i mean
maybe mocking's going too far because
that's making light of a serious issue
but it's kind of pointing to the fact
that we're not really able to do
anything when it comes to these issues
and if canada decides on a whim oh yeah
we want to tighten gun laws they're able
to go through the process pretty easily
and do it and it's interesting also
seeing right-wingers in the u.s respond
to what trudeau is doing in canada
because obviously they can't fall back
on the second amendment argument they
don't have a second amendment argument
in canada so they have to sort of
argue on the merits they have to talk
about like well will this actually make
society safer and when it gets down to
those types of arguments the right seems
to fall apart because you can compare
the states with more guns you can
compare the countries with more guns and
now they tend to have more gun crimes
and so you know this idea of more guns
and more places making everyone safer
they're not really able to argue that
effectively that's what they kind of
have to do they're kind of forced into
that position when they have to talk
about this new law in canada and they're
not doing so well when it comes to it so
it's also interesting watching that
happen the other part about will this
make canada safer this is so depressing
but experts are saying
the majority of the handguns involved in
crimes in canada
weren't obtained in canada they came
from the united states so i mean that
that's incredible on multiple layers on
one layer because we say well we'll
first of all how bad of a problem is gun
violence in canada not nearly as big of
a problem as in the united states when
there is gun crime 60 of the time it's
handguns but the overwhelming majority
of that time the guns came from the
united states anyway and were brought
over the border illegally so once again
we are even partially responsible the
ease with which you can get guns in the
united states is at least partially
responsible for the relatively little
amount of gun violence in canada it's
it's extraordinarily depressing
yeah i suppose that goes back to the
conversation about how you may not be
able to stop all gun crimes but that's
not an excuse to do nothing sure if
anything that's a reason to do more and
so if this uh handgun ban this temporary
hold isn't able to accomplish all that
they want to accomplish it's still good
that they're pursuing it because there
will be some unforeseen and foreseen
tragedies that can be averted due to a
law like this so it's good at least that
they're they're moving forward on it and
it's also interesting that you know
they're moving towards handguns as a
response to seemingly the mass shootings
that have taken place here in the us
because you know when we talk about
these different types of uh violent
scenarios we'd like to disaggregate
everything right we talk about handgun
violence being different than like a
mass shooting where the weapon of choice
tends to be like a semiotic semi
automatic rifle like an ar-15 uh
it's not like
gun policy is probably going to prevent
a lot of mass shootings in a school
setting or a grocery store setting or
anything like that but at least they're
trying something and they've already
gone after the semi-automatic rifles so
this is just sort of the next thing that
they can try to do we will see what
happens here and we will see what
happens there
another gun story you might remember so
we had the tulsa mass shooting yesterday
and last week we had the texas mass
shooting and then the week before we had
the buffalo new york mass shooting but
and then dozens of smaller mass
shootings in between
but in april there was the brooklyn
subway shooting
one of the victims a woman who was shot
in the brooklyn subway shooting has
filed a lawsuit against the gun
manufacturer glock and its austria-based
parent firm saying that the company is
at least partially responsible for her
being shot because it's contributing to
creating and maintaining a public
nuisance in the state of new york and
endangering the state's public health
and safety
this is going to be a test of the 2021
new york state gun law which says this
is what you're allowed to do you are if
you're a victim of gun violence you are
allowed based on the 2021 new york state
law to sue the gun manufacturers or the
dealers and then that doesn't mean you
will win it doesn't mean they will be
found responsible but you're allowed to
bring such a complaint to a court and
the gun industry said that law is
unconstitutional
a federal district judge said no the law
actually is constitutional and we are
going to
uh see where this goes i think
you know it you would really this would
really have to eat away at the gun
manufacturer's profits for them to all
of a sudden say we've got to do
something about this issue because at
the end of the day
if you're a gun manufacturer
if you know that you have a particular
liability like for example these
lawsuits you would pay someone to put a
dollar sign on this
and if you know hey you know what we're
actually more profitable by continuing
to try to sell as many guns as possible
and then just paying out a few of these
settlements rather than reducing the
number of guns we sell and reducing the
number of lawsuits we might have to pay
they'll do whatever is most profitable
assuming that the pr uh problem doesn't
get to be too big and this may not
actually make a difference to the gun
manufacturers they may have priced it in
already
well maybe they'll change their approach
as to how they advertise
their weapons because the idea with a
case like this is that glock was saying
okay you can easily conceal our weapons
right they associate their weapons with
sort of like
uh you know being a badass and and being
able to protect yourself and all these
different things that are appealing to a
certain demographic and so the person
who's suing you can say okay well that
sort of rhetoric is dangerous it's maybe
foreseen that it could lead to tragedies
because you're sort of marketing it in
this way and so if they
have to face lawsuits like this maybe
they'll assess that that's not the best
way to go about advertising their
weapons and then they'll change on that
front it's not very much but at least
it's something
because like i don't know if you can
really have a case to sue these gun
manufacturers for any and all all these
like shootings in different scenarios
but if you have a very specified thing
like this when you say okay the
advertising is the problem here maybe we
can affect the change in that way and
it's small but at least it's something
the specifics of the lawsuit say that
the marketing campaigns undertaken by
glock emphasize that these are
high-capacity magazines
that they can be easily concealed
they argue in the lawsuit that they are
advertised in a way to appeal to those
with criminal intent and that they are
glorif glorified through placement in
movies and rap music and those are the
claims that are being made
uh there um glock has not commented the
nra has not commented as of uh this
morning when this article was written
i don't have any prediction as to
whether this is going to work i mean
it's this is
a new law
and we are going to have to see but the
bigger concern i have is even if this
works to get a settlement for this
particular victim is it really going to
change what the manufacturers are doing
and i just don't know that it is
yeah we'll have to learn more about the
specifics of this case and follow it see
how it goes but if anything it's good
that these gun manufacturers can be sued
now they can actually have cases brought
against them because they shouldn't have
this protection that other industries
other things don't have
so that's a step in the right direction
at least at the very least it can make
these manufacturers take a step back and
reassess how they're conducting business
because they'll have to worry about
potentially getting sued if they're
doing the wrong thing
all right let's talk about the johnny
depp amber heard verdict we have not
talked about this on the show we have
not talked about this on the bonus show
it has been an internet sensation in
terms of the audiences that this
televised defamation case has garnered
now that it's finally over and i'm glad
it's over other than all of the appeals
that are coming and it's going to go on
for years longer but okay let's at least
say it's over for now the first case
there are a couple of interesting things
that i want to talk about here now i'm
going to give you the one minute summary
of this case johnny depp and amber heard
used to be married they are both actors
amber heard at a certain point
published an op-ed in the washington
post
saying that johnny depp had abused her
this caused johnny depp
to lose work and it damaged his
reputation so he claimed and he said
that the allegations were false and thus
defamatory johnny depp sued amber hurd
for defamatory claims amber heard
countersued johnny depp for defamatory
claims each made three claims of
defamation against the other we finally
got the verdict yesterday the jury found
that amber heard did defame johnny depp
with malice
in all three of the or the defamed
johnny depp in all three with malice and
two of the three instances and the jury
found that johnny depp defamed amber
heard in one of the three instances the
jury awarded johnny depp 15 million
dollars and awarded amber heard 2
million dollars because of statutory
limitations on punitive damages in
virginia
the 15 million dollars is reduced to
10.35 million
subtracting out the 2 million that amber
heard was awarded the net effect of
these two uh uh of all of the verdicts
is that amber heard owns owes johnny
depp 8.35 million dollars does she have
8.35 million dollars apparently not
apparently amber heard's net worth is
somewhere between six and eight million
dollars this is going to be appealed
all sorts of appeals are going to take
place okay fine that so that's what
happened
here's the interesting part for me
number one
the
verdict
suggests
that it was not
johnny depp who was the perpetrator of
domestic violence generally speaking in
this relationship but that johnny depp
was the victim of domestic violence
this has led
to an explosion in right wingers saying
this
debunks the entire metoo movement and it
shows that you really can't trust women
when they say x y or z happened and to
me it doesn't do that at all pat you
have here a very specific case a very
specific situation between two
celebrities
massive amounts of money at stake
multi
reputations worth multi tens of millions
of dollars
and to me this does nothing
ab to
to debunk or prop up anybody else's
particular claim of domestic violence
what we know is when most people say
they were sexually assaulted or raped
they're telling the truth
false allegations are very rare
when a false allegation is uncovered it
should be prosecuted we have laws
against false reporting of crimes and on
and on and on but right-wingers are
taking this as something that it really
isn't i mean my opinion of the trial
having watched a bunch of it is
it seemed to me that amber heard at
multiple instances wasn't honest and it
is widely accepted that as a jury
if you find that a witness
was dishonest once
you're allowed to assume that she's just
generally lying and that may be what
what the jury did but
that's all that this is about it's about
this particular case
right nothing has changed when it comes
to the metoo movement nothing has
changed when it comes to the credibility
of other sexual assault or harassment
allegations dealing with different
people i remember we would talk about
this constantly during the
the peak of the metoo movement in 2017
2018 when there were all these different
cases we'd always say you have to treat
all these different cases differently
the men and sometimes women that are
accused here they
there's a bunch of different accusations
different people may have done different
things and you have to take a look at
the credibility of everyone involved and
sort of think about all these different
things critically i think like sort of
the catch phrase that some many people
on the right especially take issue with
is this idea of believing all women
which to me never rang true as like oh
you're supposed to like believe them
with out a shadow of a doubt a hundred
percent whatever they're claiming is
just 100 percent true to me it was
always you believe them to the point
where you're willing to investigate it
right you're willing to take their
claims seriously enough to go through a
process to adjudicate whether what
they're saying is true sometimes that's
easier to do than others yeah sometimes
unfortunately it involves a
multi-million dollar lawsuit as this
case did and you know hopefully with a
lot of these other cases it doesn't have
to go that far especially because you
know especially if you're not high
profile you don't have the kind of money
to to bring it to court uh but i don't
think that anything has changed with
regard to like the legitimacy the
veracity of other claims that we've seen
over the past few years when it comes to
the metoo movement it just has to do
with this one instance having to do with
amber hurt and johnny depp and that's it
we can't go any further the other thing
i will say is when i've
i did not really know anything about the
allegations before this trial started
and i went in with absolutely no
preconceived notion at least consciously
well david maybe you had a subconscious
bias well maybe but if it's subconscious
then i don't even know about it but i
went in not knowing anything and when i
would just very casually state you know
it seems the relationship with was toxic
it seems they were both verbally abusive
to each other but on the specifics of
what's at the heart of the defamation
case it's not seeming to me like the
amber heard story is the more believable
one a lot of people in our audience
would write to me saying i'm
perpetuating misogyny and all these
different things
and what's disturbing about that to me
is
i i don't care about these individuals
any more than it was a curiosity of the
case
i did not go in assuming that anyone was
lying or telling the truth it was just
my opinion
as
an evaluator as an observer so to speak
and to assume that i could only come to
that conclusion because of misogyny
seemed a little bit weird it was just my
impression of the facts as stated
yeah and you should be able to assess
the facts as you see them you should be
objective in all this and you shouldn't
have these other
sort of aspects cloud your judgments so
i mean that's good that you were
straightforward and how you viewed it uh
to be honest i didn't follow the trial
all that closely i did watch the verdict
live yesterday um and i mean my sense as
it was going on was just that this was
sort of like pop culture stuff that
really doesn't matter too much
especially when you think about like
other issues going on in the world right
now absolutely the degree to which it
does matter i suppose has to do with the
metoo movement and all of that but i
mean am i wrong to say that like
it went wrong to not have really paid
that much attention to this thing not at
all didn't matter or no no no with more
important issues i don't
in particular because i think it doesn't
really have a bearing on the metoo
movement which is worth paying attention
to i think it's completely reasonable to
say i don't care about this and i'm not
paying attention i mean and again for me
it was sort of a curiosity because i
found the lawyering interesting and how
one establishes the case and works to
impeach witnesses etc but i i i think
it's completely legitimate that you
would just say i don't care and i'm not
watching
okay good i have no regrets about not
paying attention to this thing if
there's any one takeaway that we can uh
get from this trial it's that you don't
want to be dating johnny depp or amber
hurt it's just it's going to be a toxic
relationship that is a good takeaway
absolutely that that was what became uh
undeniably clear throughout the the case
so let me know your thoughts let me know
if you agree disagree with me on any
aspects of this we'll be back tomorrow
new show new bonus show